i have always been a quick learner and a
dedicated person
but due to some health issues in early
2020 i had to quit my job that did not
stop me from learning as soon as i
completed simplyland's data scientist
master program i got a job with a salary
hike of 50 percent even after a gap of
two years hi my name is shruti banker
and i work as a data scientist at
caterpillar i completed my engineering
in 2017 and got placed in m junction
service limited as an associate later in
2021 after i recovered i needed a fresh
start and for that i searched for online
courses and there were many courses but
then i took feedback from my friends and
they suggested that i should go with
simplylands data scientist course my
experience was great i believe the tutor
played an important role in completing
my journey the course helped me learn
our python ml programming languages i
gained a lot of knowledge in this domain
also the course price was nominal and
convenient for me the support team was
quick i remember i raised queries many
times and they resolved them in
stipulated time
and soon after the course was over i got
a job at caterpillar as a data scientist
with a salary hike of 50 percent this
course helped me to get more knowledge
about corporate life and how should i
present myself in the interview s
for me
god means my mother being a single
parent she managed everything so nicely
simply learned in a data
as being her younger sister i would like
to follow her footsteps as well as she's
become ideal for her family members i am
very proud of her and very happy for her
achievements
focus is really important and for any
goal you set you should take it
seriously
[Music]